welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who has no
better half and this video we're
breaking down moonlight episode 2. the
second entry in the season is packed
with a lot of easter eggs and hidden
details as well as an ending that's
somewhat of a cliffhanger i want to get
straight into it but obviously there
will be heavy spoilers so if you haven't
checked it out then check out now smash
that thumbs up button like moonlight
smash that jackal and make sure you
subscribe for videos like this every
week without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into
moonlight episode 2. now unlike the
other songs over the top of the titles
that we got last week the marvel logo
once again has its classic fanfare last
week's episode didn't really feel like a
marvel project and we pretty much had no
superpowers until the last shot this
however helps to ground us back in that
universe and we pick up in the aftermath
of the bathroom fight that got messier
than will smith and chris rock moonlight
pounded that jackal away in the bathroom
and yeah this video has already gotten
off to a bad start now this is over the
top of some sand and though it initially
seems like we might be in the desert
it's revealed to be the foot of
stephen's bed he wants more cracks up in
the mirror to try and talk to mark and i
love the iconography that we have here
are the two faces side by side so far we
haven't had mark's third personality
jake locklear yet and in case you don't
know he's a taxi driver that's basically
matches malone this persona is used to
gain intel on low-level criminals as
people tend to talk more freely when
they're in the presence of a cabbie one
of his main contacts is a man named
crawley and we know from the credits
that the living statue he meets every
week is actually the character just like
last time mirrors are used heavily
throughout the episode and we catch one
in the hr office in which stephen is
reflected in the table as he travels to
the storage locker we can see one in the
glass and he of course has an exchange
with mark in the reflection of a
container there's also a goldfish tank
at his home the back of the police car
later on and the bread bowl at harrows
going beyond this we get the river
during the chase scene and also the one
on the spire that mark impels the jackal
on stephen returns to work at the
gallery and after checking the cctv
tapes with the security guard they
watched scotty sorry steven from the
last episode interestingly you can't see
the jackal at all in any of the footage
and later on the one that appears is
completely invisible it's only upon
being struck with water that this sticks
to it and though it's tangible everyone
other than steven mark and harrow isn't
able to see it now we don't know why
this is but potentially only those that
have died are able to view them mark had
to die in order to be resurrected by
konshu and we learned that harrow was
once an avatar for the god therefore i
think they work much in the same way
like the threstrals in harry potter and
that you have to have been close to
death in order to be able to perceive
them perhaps the abilities come from the
gods themselves though and this would
explain why stephen and arthur can he is
of course now the servant of vomit and
he does say that he can no longer see
konshu so possibly only the avatars have
the ability to view them steven is fired
from the museum who understand his
mental health issues and he's given a
pamphlet from hr for therapy in
moonlight volume 8 he actually ended up
going to an institution which was
overseen by a character called dr emmett
this was actually revealed to be omit
and she had orderlies that were jackals
which chased mark through the night the
entire thing turned out to be an
illusion and she attempted to convince
mark that everything was all in his head
and that he'd been stationed there since
he was a kid we know from the trailers
that we are getting a scene in which
mark isn't a psychiatric hospital so i'd
love for us to see that as a flashback
or something that pops up later down the
line the stephen is asked to hand over
his name badge and as we know he's very
much struggling with who he is i
absolutely love the shot when he places
it down and the reflection of his face
sits between his hands almost like he's
throwing them up in confusion looks like
he's reaching and we are too and from
here we could have the mime that steven
sounds off to and he decides to go to
central london storage he doesn't think
he's been there before but the staff
recognized him in a scene that's
somewhat reminiscent in a fight club the
creative team behind the series said
that this is heavily influenced by that
movie and this moment especially feels
like when the narrator was retracing
tyler's footsteps inside the room he
comes across mark's possessions which
include a bed and several army storage
containers the bed itself is much like
what the army use and it's clear he's
been bunking out here i'd love to see us
get steven's blackout shona us in later
episodes and we could watch the missing
day in which he got a goldfish and
potentially traveled here to rest inside
the bag he finds not only a gun but also
several different currencies this is
something that a lot of agents are given
and it was shown to great effect in the
bourne identity when matt damon
discovered them himself he finds the
golden scarab which levitates upon the
wings being opened and stephen calls it
a compass which we know it's going to be
used for in egypt trailers have showed
harrow with it out here to dig so i'm
guessing they're going forward he's
going to use it to locate where ahmed is
mark comes out at this point and he
instructs steven it takes to sleep on
the bed so that he can take over we did
discuss in our last breakdown how rapid
eye movement was used to show the
characters passing over control and this
is something that typically occurs
during sleep i've had a couple of moon
night moments myself where i went to
sleep found another dude inside me and
woke up chained to a bed i can't say
that i caught can't get away with that
anyway he reveals that he's the avatar
of konshu the moon god that brings
justice i'm sorry yeah the jokes are
really bad this week now i do hope that
we get mark sergeant story and
flashbacks as it's a big part of the
character that we haven't seen before
and it could potentially introduce his
nemesis rob bushman who betrayed him out
in egypt hilariously stephen says he
eats one piece of steak and then he goes
bonkers and you might remember last week
that we learned he was a vegan however
after he realized his date wasn't coming
he ordered some and it made him meet
mark hey meat the jokes they're back on
track now steven wants to hand himself
in so he can't hurt people and he grabs
the bag before he does this though he
talks about the nhs following him with
pills and potentially this has happened
before during a psychiatric treatment
now i love the following scene which is
shot like a horror movie if you slow it
down you can actually see konshu for a
split second just as steven exits the
lockup he chases him through however he
manages to get out and here he runs into
layla she reveals she's his wife and
this is kind of interesting as my man
almost cheated and this does seem like a
good strategy to tell a wife when i end
up with my biggest fan aka you i'm
ending up with you you're gonna marry me
now layla is a completely new creation
for the series and typically it's
marlene who's his love interest in the
comics she could be a combination of
marlene and another character like
frenchie as the two are both fluent in
it frenchie's name duchamp also appeared
in the phone contacts last week and as
i've been saying it's all connected now
she's got divorce papers and this sends
steven off telling her about the scarab
however when mark says if she finds out
she's gonna get killed he pauses for a
second turns out mark wanted to get
divorced to protect her and that's
another excuse i'll be using with the
wife god damn layla you got me on my
knees
now it's theory time theory time every
time theory time time theory time period
so now that we know that mark is married
it kind of re-contextualizes last week's
date i can't see mark setting one up if
he's married and therefore it is
possible that it's jake who did it mark
comes across as wanting to protect leila
and therefore i don't think that he'd go
behind her back he's also not coming
across as a smooth womanizer so perhaps
we'll get scenes of jake chatting her up
and then asking her out now jake might
have also been the person that popped up
in the cctv at the museum though it
could definitely be mock since since
we're in theory time though although i'd
also talk about another one that i have
which is that the person on the phone
who stephen believes is his mother just
isn't there in case you don't know in
the comics stephen's mother died when he
was a child and i think that is probably
the same thing here now we do know that
she's been cast and will be played by
fernanda andrada however the actress is
quite young and therefore she'll
probably only be appearing in flashbacks
who knows when we get these but i think
they would have gone with an older woman
if they were gonna really show his
mother in the series anyway that's the
end of theory time theory time now at
this point the police arrive and we meet
detective fitzgerald this might be a nod
to molly fitzgerald a character from the
comics that became known as shamrock
fitzgerald was irish as well so they
might be linked and they could be lacing
the show with some little easter eggs
like that luckily look of the irish egg
layla goes out the window however
steven's arrested after they find his
fake passport one rule here never go
with the police when you know a guy
who's after you has people everywhere
and there's a little easter egg in his
interpol file the file number is 1975
and moonlight debuted in 1975 with the
comic book werewolf by knight 32. this
gets another note to it later on when we
get a quick cut to the roof of the bus
and we can see the alphanumeric code at
wbn0032
wbn obviously stands for werewolf by
night 32 for issue 32 and a nice classy
easter egg that i appreciated now his
assigned agent is also nick pepin who's
a crew member that's worked on over 16
marvel projects from captain america all
the way up to hawkeye they realized he
was at a site in egypt that had several
archaeologists killed at it and in the
comics mark went out to a dig with
buschmann who killed a lot of people
there and then attempted to do the same
to him he left him for dead in the
desert and he was taken before the
statue of konshu mark pledged his life
to him he became moonaid and as they say
the rest is history although the mystery
of the show is making us think mark did
it if he had killed the archaeologist
then he wouldn't have become moon knight
so i think he will of course learn that
he didn't have a hand in it turns out
they brought him into a neighborhood run
by harrow and i have been in worse
places in london you should see what
albert square is like murder there every
other week now harrow reveals he was
conscious avatar and correctly guesses
that he's instructing steven to kill him
konchu says break his windpipe which
would stop the character from talking
and it's clear that the god doesn't want
harrow to tell him the truth about
what's going on harrow says he was the
fist of vengeance which is actually
another name for moonlight in the source
material moonai annual 1 from 2019
showed other avatars of the gods and i
loved the idea that he was very much
what mark and steven once were but he
chose a different path arthur asks
whether conscious chose him because he
was easy to break or because his mind
was broken and in the comics we learned
it was the latter one of the big reveals
that's only came about recently is that
konju actually infiltrated mark's life
when he was a boy and that he's had his
eye on him for the entire time arthur
reveals that the gods can't actually do
anything without the help of their
avatars and this pretty much sets up the
battle between harrow and stephen who
will go hand in hand for their gods no
doubt down the line now the community is
built up of hundreds of people from
different walks of life but we know that
it's built from those deemed worthy by
omit i'm still hauling i hope that the
old woman last week was a nice lady and
she was taken by ome because her heart
was pure and the god needs good souls
also sometimes they're gonna pronounce
it omit sometimes i'm gonna pronounce it
armit sometimes i'm gonna pronounce it
amit i've got i'm i'm really sorry i'm a
terrible youtuber now harrow and steven
have a discussion about criminal
prevention and if you know someone will
do bad whether it's okay to kill them
kind of like the killing thanos as a
baby discussion from avengers end game
but harrow drops an interesting line
here he says omit will eradicate the
choice to do evil and this sounds like
the god might actually strip people of
their free will omit wants to wipe out
people before they sin raz konshu wants
to do it after omit is willing to kill
kids and as they say we don't do that
here yet most of them watch these videos
so i need that ad revenue however this
is somewhat playing on the idea of
original sin from the bible which states
that everyone is somewhat born sinful we
hear from the star of the last episode
every grain of sand by bob dylan and
this was released by the singer after he
became a born again christian now slowly
harrow's forces start to surround
stephen when he begins to question on
its way harrow switches gear and
realizes that he's gonna have to take
the scarab by force which is when he
starts to show the power of the cane we
learned that this belonged to the first
avatar of ahmed and that it contains a
slither of the god's power is it a god
or goddess am i being sexist anyway this
glows purple and as we've talked about
in a lot of our marvel breakdowns this
indicates that it's pulling from the
dark dimension orange is the standard
color red represents chaos golden is
cosmic and green tends to be illusionary
magic designed to trick people purple is
the dark dimension which dormammu was
cloaked in and we also saw agatha
busting it out in one division just the
glow of it makes everyone step back and
it becomes clear that it's very powerful
at this point layla enters with a scarab
and she tells stephen to summon the suit
lots of flashes on the put on the suit
part of the avengers between captain
america and iron man that feels sort of
like poetry they rhyme however with
steven being in control he's not able to
break out the moonlight costume as
easily what he does though is get the mr
knight one which is awesome to see in
this episode in the comics it was made
but here it's summoned and it's gonna be
steven's suit whilst the classic one
belongs to mark it's one of the coolest
comic book costumes ever in my opinion
and i loved seeing this show up here
using indigo's toenail with another
jackal and we see him take on a boxing
stance which has some basis in the
comics mark actually trained as a boxer
and his youth so it makes sense that
he'd have the ability to fight like this
in his subconscious subconscious hey
having that that's another good only
having that now speaking of having that
last week we announced we were teaming
up with noble chairs in overclockers uk
to give away a hero chair the winner of
that competition is on screen right now
save that to you and message me on
twitter heavyspoilers and we'll get it
sent out to you now when the jackal was
first shown in the trailer many people
thought that it was a werewolf i told
you [ __ ] said it wasn't a [ __ ]
werewolf but you [ __ ] just didn't can
listen anyway gonna let you off a bit
now as this scene is actually somewhat
riffing on the werewolf by night comic
which was the first appearance of the
character there is of course the bus
easter egg and the pair both fall in the
street with badons even being busted out
like what we get here now these have
actually appeared in the comics and
conju gave the ceremonial weapons to
mark in fists of conscious issue one
can't you see i'm giving you golden
easter eggs here and do i get a like for
those amazing puns dua now stephen uses
british slang throughout the entire
fight like brav ends and yard as well as
wag one that means what's going on brav
is what i call you and ins and yards are
basically where you live see kids bet
you wouldn't get that from that scumbag
ryanairy now the jackal slams stephen
against the bus and on the sign we can
see that there's an advert for the grc
this is the fictional group that was
introduced in falcon in the winter
soldier that reunited people separated
by the snapping blip the tagline says
reuniting you with your better half
which is a play on how half of all life
was snapped away beyond that though mark
is very much seen as the better half of
steven which he's been reunited with in
the events of the show they do a great
bit where he talks to himself in the
mirror and conscious says you're in
trouble steven as stephen hands control
over to mark which is when the costume
changes from the mr knight one to the
typical suit i love the way he pulls the
moonerangs out the symbol on the chest
and we see further moving imagery when
mark leaps across the sky this is then
shown in the river and on the rooftops
and we end with somewhat of a pyramid
poking towards it after mark impelled
the creature unfortunately during the
kerfuffle they dropped the scarab and
this is picked up by a homeless man
harrow kills him and it very much shows
that he doesn't really care about making
a better world it's only who he and omit
viewers being desirable that's probably
why he took the older woman too as she
wouldn't have had much to offer steven
is now trapped in the mirror world and
we learned that it's difficult for those
stuck there to get back control in the
jeff lemire run we very much got it
filled in how mark and stephen came to
be and we learned that the ladder was
very much an imaginary friend for him
when he was younger he didn't realize he
was an offshoot of his personality and
the two actually liked each other and
like what we have here mark says when
he's done that he'll disappear but in
the source material he was the more
dominant personality he talks about how
conscious saved his life and ends up
losing it when steven sends some home
truths mark smashes the glass and the
pyramid is swapped for another one when
he wakes up in egypt clearly he's
tracking harrow who now has the scarab
which is going to lead him to omit
konchu says some really interesting
stuff in the build-up to this namely
that marks but he belongs to him which
was also stated in the jeff lemire run
the girl also threatens to use layla as
his next vessel and from here we very
much see the jump from stephen's
perspective his head lifts in the mirror
and we catch mark sat there drowning his
sorrows about to head out on his next
mission great second episode and
normally in shows i find that the second
entry of a season is the weaker one but
this was really good and i don't know
which of the two that i prefer both
brilliant entries and i hope that you
enjoyed the breakdown i'd of course love
to hear your thoughts so make sure you
comment below and let me know yeah punk
we are in a competition and giving away
three copies of spiderman noe home on
the 15th of april and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now say that to
you then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers if you want some emails to
watch then make sure you check out
breakdown and moonlight in which you go
over the characters origins everything
you need to know about him and some of
the best comics that you should pick up
if you're interested in what's going to
happen if not then thanks for sticking
through the video i've been paul you've
been the best i'll see you on the next
one take care